you have love in your life has love made
you a better or a worse programmer
do you keep productivity metrics no no
no
I'm not not that I'm not that methodical
um I think that there comes to a point
where
if it's no longer visceral I just can't
enjoy it
like I still viscerally love programming
the minute I started like so that's one
of the big loves of your life is
programming oh I mean just my computer
in general I mean you know I tell my
girlfriend My First Love is my computer
of course
right like you know I sleep with my
computer it's there for a lot of my
sexual experiences like come on
everyone's right uh like you know you
got to be real about that and like not
just like the IDE for programming just
the entirety of the computational
machine the fact that yeah I mean it's
you know I wish it was uh
someday they'll be smarter and someday
you know maybe I'm weird for this but I
don't discriminate man I'm not going to
discriminate biostack life and silicon
stack life like so the moment the
computer starts to say like I miss you I
started to have some of the basics of uh
human intimacy
it's over for you the moment vs code
says hey George no you see no no but vs
code is no they're just doing that
Microsoft's doing that to try to get me
hooked on it I'll see through it I'll
see through this gold digger man it's
gold digger Look Me in open source well
this just gets more interesting right if
it's if it's open source and yeah though
Microsoft's done a pretty good job on
that oh absolutely no no look I think
Microsoft again I wouldn't count on it
to be true forever but I think right now
Microsoft is doing the best work in the
programming world like between yeah
GitHub GitHub actions vs code the
improvements to Python and where's
Microsoft like
who who would have thought Microsoft
and Mark Zuckerberg are spearheading the
open source movement right right
how things change oh it's beautiful